cari amici
benvenuti in un sogno questa non è la
solita iperbole che si dice ogni volta
dentro un bellissimo edificio perché qui
dentro quasi 500 anni fa si è
materializzato un sogno far rinascere il
teatro degli antichi romani
il teatro è una parola chiave per il
rinascimento una parola magica è un
luogo laico dove riunirsi in alternativa
alle chiese dove stare insieme provare
emozioni riso rabbia divertimento gli
uomini del rinascimento conoscono il
teatro attraverso i libri leggono plauto
terenzio leggono le tragedie greche di
eschilo e sofocle e vogliono
ricostruirlo ci provano un po tutti ci
prova bramante ci prova raffaello ma
l'unico che riesce a farlo veramente e
palladio certo come dire palladio non ci
arriva per caso studia per anni passa
mesi e continui a roma studia tutti i
teatri a pola a verona arriva fino a
napoli ma non è semplicemente lui il
maestro di questo teatro
c'è anche qualcun altro e se alzate gli
occhi e guardate dietro di me li vedete
sono gli accademici olimpici pensate che
in cambio di 10 ducati come vedete il
found raising non lo abbiamo inventato
noi si poteva avere la propria statua
nel teatro olimpico così provate a
immaginarvi il gioco dei poiana dei
pieni e dei chiericati che erano seduti
dove siete voi adesso si vedevano se
stessi rappresentati nelle statue
l'accademia olimpica era una specie di
una via di mezzo fra un associazione
culturale un istituto di ricerca e cosa
unica in italia teneva insieme nobili e
intellettuali ma perché questa strana
alleanza fra potere e cultura
l'obiettivo era costruire il futuro
perché dovete sapere che i nobili
vicentini non erano dei grandi
possidenti che vivevano di rendita ma
erano tra i più grandi produttori di
seta in europa che commercializzavano in
tutte le città
vicenza all'epoca era piena di zone
industriali come quella che vedete qui
vedete quei mulini lungo il fiume siamo
a ponte pusterla
ecco in quei volumi in quei mulini si
filava la miglior seta d'europa e le
famiglie vicentine le famiglie nobili
l'andavano a vendere ovunque ad anversa
francoforte a ginevra a norimberga
mandavano i loro figli a imparare le
lingue per commercializzare i loro
prodotti
addirittura i come si dice oggi innovant
vano il prodotto perché quando la seta
comincia a non andare abbastanza bene si
inventano le mezze lane cioè delle una
specie di antenato del jeans che mette
insieme cascami di lamanna e cascami di
seta una stoffa molto robusta e che
vende moltissimo ma perché questa questa
classe dirigente così dinamica di casa
in europa il nord est
pensate che manchester a 3.000 abitanti
nel cinquecento arzignano né a 7.000 ci
sono 400 telai a schio perché questa
classe dirigente sceglie palladio come
proprio architetto beh quando uscirete
da qui
fatemi un regalo andate in contrà porti
e guardate questo bellissimo palazzo e
un palazzo tardo gotico vedete le
finestre sono di pietra lavorata molto
ricche l'ha addirittura il portale
incrostato di marmi ma la cosa
interessante vedete che la porta non è
al centro della casa e spostate anche le
finestre si aprono più o meno dove serve
ma soprattutto se ci fate caso vedete
che la strada curva e il palazzo curva
con lei 80 anni dopo palladio deve
costruire un palazzo a fianco a quel
palazzo tardo gotico
e vedete cosa fa fa perno su un angolo e
raddrizza al palazzo totalmente
indifferente al fatto che si crei
davanti al palazzo quello strana piazza
rettangolare ma questo è perché per
palladio conta il suo progetto l'idea di
avere un lotto una direzione non c'entra
che la strada gira io ho il mio progetto
dovete pensare che è questo l'uomo al
centro del cerchio di leonardo essere al
centro del cerchio vuol dire voler
essere protagonisti del proprio destino
voler decidere non importa se la strada
gira
io ho il mio progetto ma questo non
basta
dovete immaginare che palladio passa
mesi anni a roma e misura vedete questo
è uno dei suoi disegni misura
minutamente i pezzi dell'architettura
antica ma cosa sta cercando
lui sta cercando l'algoritmo sta
cercando le matematiche
dell'architettura antica sta cercando la
regola che lui sapeva esserci nei
monumenti antichi per cui un edificio di
palladio è come una macchina matematica
ogni elemento è multiplo di un pezzo
della colonna del diametro della colonna
non c'è una sola dimensione di un
palazzo di palladio che è casuale ma
sono tutte collegate come un enorme
gigantesco meccanismo per noi palladio e
tradizione come direi il passato ma
guardate che ai suoi tempi palladio è
trasformazione è rivoluzione questo è
come dire l'architettura quando palladio
arriva questa è l'idea di ricchezza
vedete edifici rivestiti da marmi
colorati i ricchi erano colorati nel
cinquecento i poveri si vestivano con i
colori prada grigino pesciolino i ricchi
si gli architetti si vestivano già di
nero ma a questa ricchezza dei materiali
palladio risponde con un edificio come
questo
vedete con una bellezza tutta mentale
con una bellezza astratta un colore
bianco
io penso a questi edifici palladiani
come delle grandi astronavi che calavano
nella vicenza medioevale e credo che
l'impatto che hanno avuto sui vicentini
è lo stesso che ha avuto sui parigini
lavi savoye di le corbusier
questo per dirvi che io non credo che
che i beni culturali che spazi come
questo siano il petrolio dell'italia non
penso che il nostro obiettivo sia quello
di mettere a reddito di affittarli io
non sogno una un'italia di affittacamere
una in cui come dire è una disneyland in
cui gli altri vengono a visitarla
io penso invece che la storia le radici
siano il valore aggiunto del nostro
agire sul presente
sono quello che ci dà la forza sono 500
anni dino di capacità di innovazione di
creatività
qui in italia si produce bellezza da 500
anni
le ville palladiane mica sono luoghi di
villeggiatura sono fabbriche sono luoghi
dove si produce dove si trasforma il
territorio
la cosa è che loro hanno saputo produrre
ricchezza con la bellezza
noi purtroppo non ci siamo riusciti e
quello che dovremmo fare è cercare
proprio di recuperare questa capacità ma
perché ci riescono
i contemporanei di palladio per che
studiano vicenza è la città che ha il
maggior numero di laureati di tutto il
veneto e ho trovato ieri in un diario di
uno dei committenti di palladio che
questo scrive si chiama fabio monza 11
marzo 1586 non sono uscito di casa
trattenuto senza avvedersene nella
lettura di flavio giuseppe de bello
giudaico
c'è grande imprenditore e fabio monza si
dimentica di uscire da casa perché sta
studiando la storia degli antichi romani
se vogliamo che palladio continua a
parlarci però dobbiamo studiarlo
dobbiamo continuare a lavorarci sopra le
cose che vi raccontano le sapevamo fino
a 34 anni fa sono delle novità uscite da
grandi studiosi come power birds ma
anche dai giovani come voi di 30 anni
come andrea savio come edoardo
bisogna continuare interrogare il
passato bisogna continuare a studiarlo
perché nel passato abbiamo una risposta
ai nostri problemi in un presente che
cambia così rapidamente davanti ai
nostri occhi solo il passato può darci
lo spessore critico per leggere il
nostro presente un paio di anni fa
abbiamo costruito il museo palladiano e
abbiamo cercato di non fare come dire il
mausoleo di un eroe morto abbiamo
cercato di fare un luogo dove gli
studiosi raccontano come studiano
palladio non abbiamo neanche dovuto fare
una bottega turistica ma un luogo di
ricerca un luogo come dire in cui si può
entrare e capire che cos'è palladio come
lavorava come era la sua società però al
centro del cortile
abbiamo deciso di piantare un gelso per
ricordare al centro del museo palladio
che la palladio story non è la storia di
un genio isolato che è nato per caso qui
ma è la storia di una società che ha
deciso di scommettere sulla
trasformazione sull'innovazione sul
cambiamento
dovete immaginare che l'italia del
rinascimento non era una specie di eden
ma era un paese in crisi frantumato in
piccoli stati in lotta fra loro percorse
dalle armate straniere in totale balia
delle grandi potenze europee bene in
quella crisi ricercando nella grande
architettura nel passato nel grande
pensiero del passato è nato il
rinascimento sono nato michelangelo
raffaello palladio bene nella crisi di
oggi non dobbiamo avere paura ma
dobbiamo riflettere su quella sfida su
quella capacità della cultura di
costruire in futuro su quella sfida che
allora fu vinta grazie